well a small town fire department
in new mexico right next to el paso
texas
seen a spike in rescue calls to help
abandon or
injured migrants crossing the border
sunland park
new mexico is a suburb just outside of
el paso as you can see right there
and as el paso border encounters jumped
more than 200 percent from last year
our next guest the fire department chief
fears that things could only get worse
sunland park fire department chief
daniel medrano joins us right now good
morning to you sir
good morning okay so you uh generally in
the fire department you would be sitting
you know your men and women who work for
you would be sitting in the fire
department waiting for someone
an emergency call to go help a resident
of your community but now you're getting
calls from people who are in the country
illegally
who are in trouble tell us a little bit
about that
um well there's a border fence it runs
anywhere from about
12 14 feet tall to about 30 feet tall um
on the international border
sunland park is on that border and that
part of my response district
uh what we've been seeing a lot of is
migrants who fall off the top of that
wall
and they sustained pretty significant
injuries that
of course we have to address sure so
chief uh
let's say they fall on the american side
of the wall
what do you do with them i mean they
technically they've crossed into the
country illegally
i would imagine you should report them
to the authorities
but then you're kind of one of the
authorities
well we're medical authority most of the
calls come in from border patrol
themselves
they'll either witness the fall
or see them on camera and you know make
the approach first
so most most of the calls are border
patrol's on the scene prior to us
ever getting there chief as i look at
the terrain over there
it's it's rugged do you have the kind of
vehicles you need to
address this problem uh
well fire trucks cannot make it anywhere
near uh some of these areas so we've had
to retrofit
um at least one of our vehicles so far
we're in the process of retrofitting a
military humvee that we've uh
used to use as a brush truck so uh to
get into some of the more
even more rugged areas so uh we've had
to address this um
by doing so sure sure well that means
you need
more money to address this issue is the
federal government coughing up more
cash for you because you're taking on
more responsibilities
uh we haven't seen any money from the
federal government at all this is
something i had to address
immediately so i have to use my own
budget
so getting money for the federal
government
is a little bit time consuming sure you
know one of the things though chief
is you're the fire department and you
are there to help people
in your community uh when fire breaks
out or there's a medical emergency
but now you're being asked to have this
additional
responsibility of helping people who are
breaking into the country
illegally that's um that's not exactly
what you signed up for originally
well um you know we look at every
patient the same way we don't uh
we don't ask for immigration papers we
treat every
patient as a medical patient so um
we don't know if they're in here
illegally or not that's our assumption
so
you know we treat them as such but the
number of calls your call volume has
gone up substantially hasn't it um
we anticipate or we estimate it's gone
up about six to seven percent
um especially in the southern part of
our our response district
yeah uh which is not a huge number but
um speaking with border patrol we
anticipate that those numbers should go
up um just by the uh
information that they're giving us uh
that they may see
more migrants coming over well you got
your hands full uh chief
daniel medrano we thank you very much
for joining us today from the el paso
area good luck to you sir
thank you